today i have an announcement to make
today i am announcing that next season
season 19
is going to be my last season this show
has been
the greatest experience of my life
and i owe it all to you ellen degeneres
tells her audience all good things
come to an end well i hope i know when
when people kind of
are tired of me i think i'll sense that
ahead of thursday's episode of her
long-running talk show
the comedian opens up about her decision
to say goodbye two years ago i signed a
deal for three more years
and i always knew in my heart that
season 19 would be my last
19 is a great number first of all the
19th amendment gave women the right to
vote
and this may be controversial but i
believe that women should be allowed to
vote i've said it
said it jokes aside
ellen took a moment to thank her fans
for tuning in
the past 18 years you have to know has
changed my life
you all have changed my life and i am
forever grateful to all of you for
watching
for laughing for dancing sometimes
crying
this show has been the greatest
experience of my life
and i owe it all to you in all
seriousness i truly
have felt like next season was the right
time to end this amazing chapter
but how do you end a show that's become
a cultural phenomenon
all she can tease for now is that we are
in for a celebration
18 years ago on the very first show i
said this was going to be a relationship
and we are going to continue that
relationship even when this show
ends i promise you that we are going to
have a fantastic final season
it will be a season where i truly get to
say thank you
there will be a lot of surprises there
will be trips down memory lane a few
detours
through why did i wear that alley
of course we still have a lot of
celebrating to do this season
so what's next for an entertainer who's
done it all
you may wonder why i've decided to end
after 19 seasons the truth is
i always trust my instincts my instinct
told me it's time
as a comedian i have always understood
the importance of
timing and recently i had a dream that a
bird
beautiful bird with bright red feathers
came to my window and whispered
you can still do stuff on netflix and
that was the sign i was looking for
ellen spoke to et in 2019 about when her
show would possibly end
how are you going to know when it's the
right time to walk away from daytime
um well i hope i know when when people
kind of are tired of me
i think i'll sense that i don't think
that's possible well yeah i mean
people get tired of people but and
especially in today's age
but um you know i'll walk away really
when i when i stop having fun
i actually don't care about the rest of
the people if i if i'm having fun
and no one's watching i don't care but
if i'm
if i'm not having fun and everyone's
watching then i should walk away